but tell me a little bit
uh you set up a school in hollywood
didn't you for people like
james garner and steve mcqueen and the
others yes why would they
want to learn chinese martial art
because of a movie role
not really i mean most of them you see
uh
to me at least the way that when i mean
when i teach it
all type of knowledge ultimately means
self-knowledge so therefore they're
coming
in to i mean for and ask me to teach
them not so much
of how to defend themselves or how to do
somebody in
rather they want to learn to express
themselves
through some movement be it anger
be it determination or whatsoever
so in other words what i'm saying
therefore is that he is paying me
to show him in competitive form
the art of expressing the human body
which is acting in a sense
well or it would be useful tool for an
actor to have it's
i mean i might it might sound too
philosophical but is
unacting acting or acting unacting
if you you've lost me i have
so what i'm saying actually you see i
mean it's a combination of both
i mean here it is the natural instinct
and here is control
you are to combine the two in harmony
not if you have one to the extreme you
will be very unscientific
if you have another to the extreme you
become all of a sudden
a mechanical man no longer a human being
so you
it is a successful combination of both
so therefore it is not only
i mean so therefore it's not pure
naturalness or
unnaturalness the ideal is
unnatural naturalness or natural
unnaturalness